bon voilà on voulait quand même rendre
hommage votre travail avant de parler
d'amnesty international amnesty cas donc
40 ans a été fondée en 1961 par un
avocat britannique qui s'appelle peter
benenson pour défendre les prisonniers
oubliés et i10 et cet avocat il
reprenait un proverbe chinois
il vaut mieux allumer une bougie que
maudire l'obscurité et c'est pour ça que
le symbole d'amnesty international c'est
une bougie et fils de fer barbelés
autour voilà alors en 1977 amnesty a
obtenu le prix nobel de la paix
aujourd'hui à un million de membres dans
le monde et la campagne 2000 2001
c'est donc pour dénoncer la torture qui
est encore employée par deux états dans
le monde sur trois il ya quand même deux
pays sur 3 où la torture est employé
comme un moyen de gouvernement
à lui
voilà donc comme je disais dans deux
pays sur 3 la torture est devenu un
système de gouvernement on torture plus
pour faire parler mais pour faire taire
c'est à dire que les gens pètent ils
sont intimidés par la danger d'être
torturés et il s'exprime plus oui les
choses qui est intéressant c'est que on
se demande toujours si si en parlant
avec amnesty international ou le
fédération internationale des droits de
l'homme enfin si ça fait si ça sert à
quelque chose est un cas très
intéressant
le 5 février josé un étudiant en
amérique du sud était menacé d'être mis
à mort
si de ne pas les noms des deux les
données des personnes dansant dans son
dans son lycée qui étaient les chefs
d'une révolte contre le gouvernement ont
la menaçait de mort en a même emmené
jusqu'à une rivière pour le noyer enfin
on lui a mis la pression
amnesty de nationale fen chose qui est
pour pour le première fois ils ont mis
sur internet il ya on peut consulter
stop tortue au point où hergé et
internet
eh bien il ya eu tellement de monde qui
étaient intéressés par cette affaire que
en trois jours les gars ont été libérés
et le première fois donc ça faire
quelque chose on peut toujours faire
quelque chose on voit toujours des
telles horreurs sur le télévision qu'on
se dit oui mais qu'est ce tu veux dans
ces pays là qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
eh bien on peut faire ça on peut
s'intéresser on peut consulter par
internet on peut se faire membres de
amnesty international c'est le moindre
des choses parce que parce qu'il ya
quelqu'un dans chaque pays qui veille
qui dénonce qui équipent utilisent leur
lui à faire ce qu'on aimerait peut-être
faire soi même et on n'a pas le temps on
a même un autre problème métier et c'est
le moins de choses peut-être c'est de
faire partir de amnesty et il faut une
chose plutôt joli et ça c'est le pour
les 40e anniversaire d'investissement
pour une idée très beaux ils ont ils ont
fait faire un statut qui va être mise à
l'extérieur de beaubourg un statut fait
par les universitaires de beaux-arts de
paris
et là dessus venez tous pour coller un
sparadrap
sauf si vous cavale et le 26 mai 2001
vous déposez un sparadrap pour dire je
suis pas d'accord en fait c'est tout ce
qu'on a eu dans ton je ne suis pas
d'accord c'est pas trop mon nous que
vous ferez des tortures des choses qui
sont contre mot conscience à moi il faut
dire aussi pour continuer quand même qu
amnesty été impliqué dans d'autres dans
d'autres choses
la tchétchénie pour qu'ils continuent
puis quand tu parce que le torture
continue parce que j'ai vu l'échelle 1
dollar
le ministère de santé qui venu en france
à briser ses bras pour qu'il puisse pas
opérer il est obligé de repérer dans les
sous sols où il est obligé d'enlever
plus de bras et des jambes il ne sait
pas il fait plus de chirurgies en [ __ ]
at her que de chirurgie esthétique que
dans ce coin là et c'est parce que ça
pourri parce qu'ils allaient gangrène et
dans les sacs tout ça en impression
parce que c'est pas sur les télés
actuellement voilà voilà que ça ça a été
ça s'est pas arrêté on n'ose pas être
fâché avec des russes donc
donc en fait rien tu peux faire quelque
chose tu peux dire je ne suis pas
d'accord je vais manifester avec amnesty
où justement nous une liste c'est odile
d'accord pas d'accord passé au dessus de
la raison d'état à ce qu'un risque rien
donc il ya des gens avec une courage
heymans dans le pays où ces espaces qui
osent faire quelque chose et nous ici on
risque rien du tout oui mais pas à cause
de leboeuf ou la vache folle ou les
choses qui nous un vol et on peut au
moins dire quand même on peut passer
cinq minutes un collier de paravent vous
êtes impliqué dans la lutte contre le
sida
l'algérie le tibet les enfants de la
terre avec yannick noah
les téléthons est ce que finalement
commencé reid vous êtes une des rares il
y en a beaucoup enfin disant vous êtes
quand même une des rares artistes à
autant vous engager pour des pour des
causes humanitaires
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas peur à un
moment d'en faire trop on ne peut pas
arrêter là on m'a demandé si je vais à
roanne des pendentifs et oui on peut
raconter ses efforts dans ces calories
qui va aller apprendre à peut-être
personne d'eau je trouve ça irrésistible
à chaque fois j'apprends surtout la
conduite rice si tu penses que des
choses vont mal tu apprends que qu'il y
a des gens qui font des trucs tellement
surprenant dans une huitaine
désastreuse que finalement tu sors
enrichi pas les personnes que tu as
rencontré donc c'est même peut-être pas
dire ça on passe aux téléspectateurs
plutôt que d'être malheureux ici quasi
de ceux qui sont plus malheureux que
vous ailleurs prendre l'avion pour faire
le bien quoi on n'est pas obligé d'aller
au bout du monde on peut aller au coin
de la rue effectivement merci la france
est en fait gêne vous avez commencé à
militer avec votre père qui est un héros
de la deuxième guerre mondiale et vous
faisiez démarche à londres contre la
peine de mort
et quand vous êtes arrivé en france en
68 vous avez continué à exercer pas
quelque chose qui vous a pris
une fois que j'étais devenu une vedette
cirque dès votre plus jeune âge votre
père vous avez g concernés avec ses
problèmes
votre mère grande comédienne de théâtre
qui se permettait de refuser des rôles
avec peter o'toole parce que je n'ai pas
les ailes je n'ai pas à dire elle n'est
pas guérie chrome os voilà pour pas
choquer papa est ce que les français
savent pas ce que les français savent
pas c'est qu'en angleterre dès qu'on
parle de ça c'est qu'en angleterre avant
avant votre arrivée en france avant
slogans avant serge gainsbourg donc le
film de pierre grimblat avance ici enfin
tout l'art il était déjà vachement connu
allant vous viviez avec john barry qui
est un très grand compositeur
on va écouter ce qu'il a vécu
j'en ai besoin
macadam cowboy et maicon
bien donc comme quoi j'aime leur pin
finalement avant gainsbourg vivait déjà
quand même avec ap droits d'auteur avec
un compositeur oui c'est vrai
délicieusement ouais mais quand j'étais
mariée avec john
c'est vrai que newsweek avait dit john
barry et sans jaguar type e et ça fait
un petit peu je ne sais pas s'il est
vraiment un compliment
donc je pense que si jeune si lui
n'était pas barré en amérique et que moi
j'avais pas sorte de grand coup dans le
derrière pour me débrouiller
j'aurais rester une femme assez banal à
a coulé son bain est une sorte de deux
femmes à la maison parce que je
l'admirais beaucoup et puis j'avais ma
fille kate personnage infiniment
méritait elle même parce qu'elle a créé
elle même de société pour les drogués
des alcooliques en france et maintenant
photographe très estimable donc qu'est
tout est quand même venu de 7,7 marquage
avec john barry qui marquera t il je
voulais partir et partir des makes alors
ce qu'il faut dire aussi c'est qu'à
l'époque en angleterre
vous avez fait deux films très important
de nac de richard lester qui a fait
après tout les films des beatles avec
charles rampling jacky cette gt
débutants de toutes les trois blow up
d'antonioni qui a été un succès
considérable et john barry faisait un
peu poussé à faire bleus à vous vouliez
pas c'est pas tellement ça je suis parti
pour faire un essai et puis on m'a dit
qu'il fallait que j'écris mon nom sur le
mur alors j'ai commencé très petits
comme ça et puis à chaque 3e l'aide
qu'il fallait je tourne un profil donc
je suis pas très fort mal de gestion des
billets et puis tout d'un coup un fou
italien est sorti en disant pourquoi
vous faites ça c'est pense c'est pour ça
que vous croyez que vous allez attraper
l'oeil de le mettre en scène
vous pensez que c'est comme ça que vous
aurez du succès sur le rival de m et
puis antonioni a dit voilà c'est tout
coupé je voulais juste voir si elle est
émotionnel et puis il a dit vous avez le
rôle mais je vous donne trois pages de
votre rôle
mais il va falloir vous mettre à poil
alors
je suis rentré à la maison et c'était
correct de dire que je suis parti à la
maison et puis j'ai dit à john que voilà
que j'avais le rôle mais ces points
antonioni que j'ignorais qu'ils
s'étaient bien sûr il a dit mais c'est
quand même si on va se mettre à poil vos
quelqu'un antonioni vie meilleure mais
les scènes du monde
mais il a dit vous allez jamais pouvoir
oser parce que vous étiez toujours tous
les lumières tout le temps pas vendeur
avant de se mettre nu et dont il a dit
touré j'aime le courage etc et passent
justement il fallait pas le dire parce
que ouais il nous a dit pas si je veux y
est allé voilà c'est comme ça ça s'est
passé
qui peut dire aussi jane c'est que bleus
a pas eu un énorme succès palme d'or à
cannes en 64 et un jour john barry vous
appelle de new york et il vous dit c'est
incroyable les gens font la queue tout
autour de times square pour pourvoir le
film enfin dans ce que vous avez compris
que vous aviez fait un truc très très
forte
oui je suis enceinte et quitte donc
super summer et connaissez je n'arrivais
même pas à rentrer à la projection
privée de blog parce que j'étais bloc
mais tellement vague alors j'étais un
peu inquiet et j'ai envoyé ma mère et je
dis va voir si j'ai fait une chose en
tout elle dit menons durée crabots fille
dans une piscine c'est absolument
charmant à ça tout le monde m'a dit
quand c'est les choses de plus je compte
complice faire j'avais fait quel effet
pas chef la route elle était une comédie
musicale de john barry d'ailleurs sur
scène comme ça que je les ai connus et
avant ça j'avais fait une pièce green
green qui a fait grand scandale parce
que ce ralph richardson de nos plus
grands acteurs étaient en train de de
cuisine il était sculpteur des parties
privées de dieu déjà lui il a reçu tous
les insultes possible et en fait - oui
avec avec blow up ça fait un scandale
s'ils voulaient pas que les filles
étaient est ténue en fait et est
paraît-il pour les poumons et
projections des mecs avec des positions
en dvd on avait des petits bouts qui
fait que le film devenu de plus en plus
où ils ont enlevé les images absolument
alors pourquoi il est parti john barry
pourquoi vous est ce pas parce que
j'étais certainement pas je ne savais
pas le garder où ça va garder des mecs
mais d'une autre manière
heureusement qu'il est parti parce que
sinon quand je t'ai dit c'est peut-être
faire les choses qu'on apprend dans la
vie c'est que quand il vous semble que
c'est une des ars complet ça me semble
un désastre complet il était divin il
était allé en tue je comprenais même pas
pourquoi ils me regardaient dans la
comédie musicale iris 8 autres filles
est infiniment plus belle que moi je me
sentais comme si j'étais bordé de
nouilles d'avoir eu ces petites génial
il a eu trois oscars du jour comme un
fils aîné 3 on fait deux oscars et il ma
fille le même jour je me suis dit que
vraiment j'avais une chance fou en
peluche aimer la musique
alors c'est vrai que quand il était
parti oui je sais je me suis dit bon je
n'étais pas l auteur de de savoir
techniquement d'être peut-être personne
qui savait faire des trucs bien pour le
garder parce que ce moment là bah oui à
ce moment là vous pouvez aller chercher
un langage non mais curieusement juste
moi que c'est bizarre ça te secouer un
peu j'avais mafiques et il fallait
gagner des sous j'avais mon honneur
quand même je pourrais retourner chez
mes parents je les fais mais après je
voulais voilà est avoir des ressources à
moi et quand gramblat est venu chercher
une fille vraiment je le remercie celui
là parce que sinon toute ma carrière je
n'aurais jamais eu et j'arrive et puis
je tombe sur seiche qui lui aussi est
être un homme triste parce que il été
quitté par cobra bardot donc on n'était
pas du tout les gens aussi banal veut
dire lui je m'en souviens très bien dans
un restaurant à saint tropez
moi j'étais dos à la porte mais il était
face à la porte et puis j'ai vu devenir
blême et je me retourne et c'est parce
qu'il avait vu bardou et on était sur la
piscine mon fils delon dont s'est dit
pas encore patché et moi quand john
barry venise aussi on nous présente sa
table et ses aventures
ça fait peur mais nous oui
éducateur à la recherche de oui et puis
moi lund quand john barry venez pour
chercher quitte pour la sortie et je les
regarde et qui partait dans la rue dit
vivement
main dans la main et puis celle cgt sur
le piano en visite en attendant que ça
le rendait furieux n'était pas encore
patché donc ça prend du temps pour ce
patch est et puis après sable non aux
patchs aussi bien que belle histoire la
suite on la connaît